[Music]
scp-1128 also known as The Aquatic
horror is an entity classified as Euclid
in the SCP foundation's database it
manifests as a gigantic Marine Predator
to anyone exposed to a full description
of it either written spoken or visually
depicted people affected by scp-1128
initially display no unusual behavior
but often develop an aversion to
water-based activities once fully
immersed in water they disappear beneath
the surface regardless of the depth only
to reappear in a state of panic moments
later or in some cases not at all with
the water being contaminated by their
remains those who return intact claim to
have been transported to a vast ocean
where they were chased by scp-1128 these
accounts risk further contamination as
descriptions of the creature tend to
trigger additional cases amnestics have
been found effective in treating
scp-1128's effect notably testing
revealed that the entity can appear in
increasingly smaller bodies of water to
those exposed over prolonged periods